what's up guys Mary here along with Mike
they episode 4 resident evil I got a
bunch of stuff to resident kidney
belches well this is resident evil this
works for the first game that we play I
can actually say resident evil cuz it
makes sense
I have gun ammo a lighter full canteen
shotgun with only two shells it's not
that great and I have an armored key and
we've only opened one door with that so
far
yeah you have a bunch more for that I
probably tell we've also uncovered a few
good things if I could just go into this
box real quick
should I combine these with some of my
shotgun carry realm or shells I have
this chemical I haven't been able to use
that yet incendiary shells that sounds
nice and we got the masks oh yeah one of
those I'm trying to think if you even
need the shotgun right now I mean if you
feel safer you'll probably feel safer
with it that's understandable but I
don't think you need it I have so much
gun ammo like Ray my regular handgun is
70 bullets like I feel pretty solid so
I'm okay with that but if I could just
back out of that real fast we just we
just got one math but I feel like I'm
not actually sure besides just going
into rooms with the armor key I don't
know what else to do yeah do that I mean
you still have a lot of the mansion you
haven't found yet okay so anywhere in
particular or should I bring anything
just in case that you would recommend
looking at you and chemical I would
bring like no I think you're good you'll
find green herbs along the way I feel
okay mhm
we just saved some not to worry about it
yes you're on the east side of the
mansion is there any zombo's on here a
hearing room it's been a week since we
recorded already also to anyone who was
like you guys aren't gonna not finish
this until like 2020 we did oh this is
the one I don't I'm not allowed to go in
here right
yeah don't use that door he's gonna yell
at me no I was actually gonna let you do
it and then let you suffer because that
would have sucked if you did I'm still
figuring out when to guide you and when
to let you die no I'm gonna die so the
map becomes helpful when you're trying
alright so I'm gonna take a left and
then try that right door that red one a
lot of these I can't remember what key
it is oh oh ho ho
that's that's my excited Oh
Oh a red plant can I take these now and
combine them I have a story no not yet
like you can very soon just uh not yet
okay there is a large scratch in the
wall it doesn't look like the work of
those rotting freaks
what a jerk thing to call them I know it
seems unnecessary they were people once
um what does that blue thing mean so it
just mean it's open
mm-hmm like okay all right let's go in
there
the other ones read this one so yeah a
general rule of thumb if you're kind of
if you know you're exploring this like
isolated area I would explore the whole
area before you decide what to pick up
because like say you find herbs like
right now great or first instinct is to
pick those up right it might be like a
story centric item right which is and
they're not gonna leave you can come
back here you're right next to a save
room can I come back here I'd like to
comment on this it won't let me so
pretty like read it's a pretty creepy oh
angle that they had the camera they do
that a lot in these oh speaking of
creepy angles I was just about to say
you seem a little less tense than last
time and I can't have that have you ever
gone into your bedroom and then there's
looks like there's someone under the
sheets and then yes they jump out of you
know after you read it no these
footprints look like they're headed
straight through the bed oh there's a
secret under there definite secret I
will take that for
should I not take the 4c okay I get a
second leave it there it'll still be
there right I would say just check out
the rest the area before yeah there's
nothing in the drawers are you one of
those people that says that no from New
Orleans no drawers
some people say underwear like that
right drawers I guess I'll just leave
that to ya I mean considering the
proximity to a save room right now I
would say a lot of these like healing
items are not a priority to bring back
right now oh [ __ ]
secret green herb oh [ __ ]
secret green earth sorry I'm just kind
of like looking I can't see this wall
can i push this the bed I'm sorry I mean
the camera angle actually like really
confuses me a lot I can't push the bed
it's one of those points where you can
almost tell just by the art the actual
artwork for the bed that it's kind of
part of the environment and not
malleable that makes sense
yeah I don't think I can move it it must
be a switch so I'm gonna say nothing
else in this room because I I touched
everything mm-hmm
but maybe in that other room check it
out I will check it out Mike
go do it I will only use my lockpick the
chances of zombie being the other side
of a door with a lockpick door are
pretty high why you're just messing with
me zombie kills I'm actually like that
his scent
a letter is slipped inside the top part
of the letter is torn off the rest of
the letter is eligible oh ma I have
tried to survive only to see you again
but my efforts only delayed the
inevitable I am infected and there is no
cure for what will follow except to end
my life before I lose the only thing
that separates me from them my love for
you in an hour I'll have entered my
eternal sleep where there is peace
please understand please know that I am
sorry Martin crack horn his name
completely ruins the sentiment of that
entire letter I lost mine yesterday
let's continue our investigation
yeah a pretty little thing to say mm-hmm
I like the bubbles in this room they're
soothing a little bit an unlocked case
it's full of various biological reports
whoo I will take the B specimen that
sounds important I've made that call I'm
making the call go for it oh [ __ ]
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute uh yeah never mind take I don't
do what you want you'll figure it out
yeah
the lure of the B now I don't have any
spots
what there's a white lab coat hung up
here it smells vaguely like a medicine
cabinet I'm gonna check this one again
anything else I need to know about an
unlocked case it's full of reports I
think that's it
perhaps someone was using it to raise
some kind of creature jeez that's pretty
specific I I don't see anything else I
already pressed it yeah you pressed it
you really do anything to the first
though I'm gonna examine these things
what does b-but its stinger his semen is
what demon you're misleading rhymes
that's a term all right check
entomologist
there's no hook on and said oh okay um
do I need to take the hook from the
other one the other one was a real be
like a dead bee oh the likes of which
don't come with hooks all right I just
thought I'd try well I don't have a hook
from anywhere else where can I get a
hook do I need a hook maybe I don't even
need one I don't even know what I'm
using this for let alone so if you
examine something and then it changes
its caption at the bottom that's usually
a big hint yeah I need a hook
you're pretty good defensive items three
daggers I think you have a battery pack
as well thank you for your stun gun yes
Donna I alright you have an exam in this
whole room okay
I know it's full of dead bugs we've
discussed this yeah I remember the water
oh haha no here you can you can put the
regular be back on its thing and then
get the hook and combine them I guess I
don't need the B maybe I do well sorry I
misspoke I can't put the be back alright
so keep in mind one of these frames is
real insects that insects the other is
fishing lures so this one has dead
insects no that's those law books on no
I meant this container full of dead bugs
and then this is the actual insects and
there's a switch yeah and nothing
happens
all right [ __ ] all right so I'd like to
like yeah there you go thank you
now you can get the hook I'm very smart
can I press the thing you know you try
you're damn right now I'm gonna examine
it okay that didn't I don't regret not
doing it that's all right there you go
boom
okay so mystery solved almost that's it
you just had to swap them that's not
that's a funny it shouldn't be that
tricky of a puzzle but it did trick me
oh wait no oh wait I do need to take it
no no just wait go through this problem
okay I'm just a weird hot-diggity-dog
grab that [ __ ] I will grab Oh use your
gun can I kill it well get volume you
know I feel about bees that's a huge be
its huge be do I ever come back touch me
get out of there with away from that
bumble [ __ ] survived the bumpy attack
it's been a while since a be scared me I
got stung in my face last year what to
bring my doorbell in my old house cuz I
lock I locked out and there's a business
in the doorbell like hollow it stung you
right between my eyes there's an
accurate actually a nightmare scenario I
stomp the [ __ ] out of that thing okay so
that's the wind key
mm-hmm well it's the start mm-hmm I
don't have the rest of the key mm-hmm I
have some of the wind key wait what key
no it's just a crest okay you have no I
have not weren't on the same page are we
I don't think so if you want you could
start taking those you're keep in mind
you're writing the save room so you
could probably deposit I really wouldn't
even worry about the shotgun right now
okay like worst-case scenario you
because I can't even combine these items
right now
no can I check the bed again or do you
think you can grab that first aid kit
I'd rather greet you grab that okay cuz
I probably won't come in here for a
while no you could leave those things
here it's like I said it's it's helpful
to get as many healing items in the safe
because then I can have them everywhere
yeah there's nothing in the drawers my
yuto filthy paws off my toe good job
greased lightning oh yeah you referenced
long before my time oh that's a good
reference my drawers it's part of the
song right yeah to my knowledge of
grease and lightning all right so the
save room is down these stubs so I'll
just quickly deposit a few knick-knacker
knacks maker necks yeah which is another
word for drawers knickerbockers knickers
okay nope
yep does this music comfort you yet yes
cuz it's the only time I do feel safe I
might need that windcrest your good
without it right now for a while I don't
really think I need this thing either no
but I need this and I need these I'd say
you're good now yeah like I like I said
worst case scenario I'll just dodge
those arms some you've been calling them
thumbs zombies alright a lot of slow
start to the episode but we'll get into
some stuff what you know oh the BN air
mine the B he was did you even lose any
health from him no permeate I don't
think so no you're fine unless he stung
you and poisoned you and you don't even
know shut up all right
all right so there's another locked room
in here
I forget what was in this room to be
honest with you I I forget this is one
of those ones that I scared you out I
scream when you walk through I think I
could have done it again right there
this is where you got the second floor
map above the fireplace I think it'd be
cool to combine a plan I haven't done it
yet yeah you could now you can pick up a
red and green and combine them cuz I
know you're still fairly close to a save
room I would just leave those there look
if you know you're getting closer to
hell man save and then you can start
just like hoarding healing items all
right okay so we're not gonna do that
we're gonna move on alright let's keep
going cuz we have a whole key there was
a there was a bunch of doors that had an
armored key so we have so much to do
here oh [ __ ] sorry sorry okay so I've
done this whole hallway yeah so I'm
gonna go down to this dangerous area
where there's there's a zombie r-right
somewhere I'll go through that door
and into this red area word up sick do
it I will
don't oh wait i'm not allowed to go
through the store yeah you are you can't
go through that right one I can go
through this one them hmmm that room to
the rights where you get the lighter I
also scared you in there
your tricks only work once those three
times but once one episode at a time one
to three times I think I could get you
again I feel like there's a zombie in
here but you got that mask there that's
right dumb puzzle it's uh sorry the
camera is changing direction yeah you
can not only do these controls kind of
not make you miss nice they don't make
you miss the old controls but it kind of
highlights why the old controller useful
because it's relation to the character
or not the actual oh no
Oh nurtured Richard you're wounded this
whole place is a killing zone there are
monsters what did this you
big snake what and it had to be
poisonous poisonous Richard hold on
we're cherry syrup Richard super-dead
it's awesome bringing heat I'll go and
get it okay
you're gonna make it
where's the serum I don't remember serum
I feel like I would remember something
like it's the other safe room
all right that's on the other side
interests of saving him oh is it time
based yes
so what in terms of minutes yeah is it
starting well I don't I'm actually not
sure but I can tell you the fastest
route and I could show you but Richard
pretty much just follow the blue wait
what am I looking at
yeah okay so what do you want to know
what I think or do you want me to just
you just yeah so this is that close out
of this no no no I might have already
started yes actually no no so where
which way do you plan on going well I
was gonna use the map oh yeah go for it
but like kind of be quick about it yeah
okay yeah you're good so just yeah you
got it be quick about it
posthaste it's Carol the movies in year
1920 trying to be anybody but like a
21st century season oh no isn't there
Zalman here knows the main hall is
always safe okay all right so straight
ahead I already forgot now straight
ahead through here mm-hmm
as fast as you can without wasting time
looking at the map what stop
you're in the hot seat girl I don't want
him to die I can't believe it's actually
timed so I've never actually saved him
no I've saved them oh god there's a
zombie in here can I make it you are
pushing it boldness doesn't always pay
off plus one where is he you still there
well keep going okay I see you seen I'm
doing I'm baiting him so I can get cuz
like do I wanna get in the left room
yeah the left room mm-hmm
hold on Richard this is a new element of
this game that I really appreciate like
I I'm not as scared
Oh God Oh God is there somebody in there
mmm that noise I think is when someone's
trying to follow you to the door or no
come through a door I don't know yeah I
would just say hurry okay gonna have you
probably you have needs I have to dodge
here it's aren't there's three wait
aren't there two crimson heads in here
are there yeah oh [ __ ] well okay just if
you survived on the safe room you'll be
fine just do that I'm not going to safe
room I was gonna go to that no that that
is the safe room it's the serum room is
the safer down the stairs yeah to go
downstairs oh I'm not gonna make any
well yeah you will yeah you got your
good I died
oh you almost had it yeah okay I thought
you had it I thought I did to it when I
heard the camera yeah I went past the
door yeah all right whatever
that was a shitstorm of Chad's okay
there was three I dodged two and I felt
so good about myself lesson learned
I lost a lot of progress no no you were
just taking now you know how
that puzzle you don't even have to do
that puzzle right now let's no let's do
Richard get that out of the way then
we'll go back what's uh yeah that sucks
do richard first and then worry about
the puzzle later so you can just ensure
that you do it but I would bring first
time that's ever happened I would bring
the shotgun with me this time I
completely forgot we had three crimson
heads in there too as soon as I opened
they knew I think the third one was a
regular zombie but yeah those stairs
screw you up but that's kind of [ __ ]
that they can oh wait I have the shotgun
alright so I'll get rid of these ink
ribs we're gonna save save Richard oh
wait do I need more shells two shells a
lot I mean you could put in your
inventory combine them and then put the
neck of the last two in the inventory
are back in the item box yeah that's
what I'm going to do man you dodged
those first two really well right now it
was just a matter of the camera which
has about it because I had it hey what
the stairs like I'm trying to think
freaking at it I died should I make it
my primary you could you won't have to
fire it for until you get back there
this pisses me off
hey losing progress that's the scariest
part the thing is if you I'm glad you
brought six shells because if you're
gonna shoot them to knock them down I
would just recommend finishing them off
because otherwise those come back yeah
with full health well yeah I forget
where Richard was sorry I just get
confused so this red door right here
right is the one of the B puzzle which I
like again just leave that for later
right so I'm going oh I'm going into
this mm-hmm
here yeah yeah passed the statute really
good no eyes nose or mouth
I can't believe I died not over it yet
what don't leave me badass yeah
oh so that's another thing if I would
have faced him I would have lived yeah
but then you at that point even if you
were facing him and he's a dagger he
would have gotten down yeah you wouldn't
barely go in the door I should you know
what I should have done too is I could
have paused and like maybe taking a
Health or something because I had a
health kit on me I think I made all
these mistakes cuz I was panicking
classic panic you know it'll be useful
to kill them anyway if you do because
they suck yeah damn you could skip this
I can can you skip oh I don't know you
should be able to get this Richard
scared me okay
you're wounded there you go there's a
giant snake how big you think the snake
would have to be to make it that big of
a dam um
not like all right I already forget how
to do this
not like anaconda sized but big all
right I forget what I'm doing yeah this
doesn't show you where you are come
toward the camera I'll take a left
yeah got it okay you're making good time
do you think yes I think I would have
saved him I think so so I never I always
for a while that it would depend on how
many doors you open so you had to
literally take the shortest route
possible but I think it is just time
after talking to other people this is
right right yeah Pass pleases Allah play
the moist second-guessing everything
like my whole life come here come on
come here cat
does he I think he starts in the right
door anyway so you should be able to for
him
I hope okay so wait there's two dudes in
here right
wait there's three well the I don't
think it's a guarantee that that third
one's gonna always come busting oh
really oh nevermind I wouldn't worry
about though I don't think he's crimson
head these three go wait to line it up
if you can oh [ __ ] okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah [ __ ] I'm sorry it's alright it's
alright don't worry about this guy
really yeah I need a way I don't have to
burn them so what am i doing both blood
you're good you have a safe room alright
so what do you have one [ __ ] used it
extra shell and accidents because I
panicked
the yeah you don't have the death
animations for them yet it's fine
that guy you could I'm wondering where
he's gonna start when you go back in
because you could just use a defense or
just handguns great you'll have time but
yeah okay so don't even worry about
shotgun Hamel right now just go go yeah
I really don't remember how it's time
you have no you're good as long as
you're hurrying you'll be fine okay I
would not use a shotgun shot on his
regular guys oh all right you might not
even have to kill him every decision I
make takes like three times as long as
I'm freaking out
harness the panic oh [ __ ] he's right
there oh nice hot dodge [ __ ] denied
right okay good so he'll be on my left
yes I believe so
moves oh yeah you come through that door
now man I can't get that down
you know it's it's amazing how that
first zombie scared the absolute crap
out of me and now I'm like just avoiding
him and he's annoying it's like I have
bigger problems than a zombie mm-hmm oh
crap where am I going okay I'm going
this way yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
Richard you're making good time
reach your head rich Oh P okay imma save
you oh [ __ ] Mary did you pick up the
serum at the poison because you can get
poison I showed up it's in here right
yeah good there's a cuts just gone yeah
he looks like crap no no you're gonna
make it being voice acted by a 14 year
old most depressing line in the game
he's alive Oh
and Richard walked into my life that day
and never never left the door with the
wind of it there's way more plants here
than I thought but I have I'm fine
getting complete healing he's not good
yet oh I need to heal him I'm doing any
time I think you're getting too common
all right I'm gonna go to the store
cuz I haven't been through it yet dude
it well oh I will oh oh
all right feeling better about her
progress that puzzled be puzzle taking
no time now that you know how to do it
right but there's a door down these
stairs and then there's a room to the
left mm-hmm what do you think left well
left rooms unlocked might as well try it
on left the red door defense sad that
[ __ ]
I did good is he dead back off double
knife Jesus double nice got a lot of
knives in his face he got double weight
yes blood I see it
hot it's also worth paying attention to
like the geography of the corridor where
you are burning them because if it's
like a wide-open space you don't need
the broom because you dodge merrily but
like in this area like this it's
probably good to burn them because less
room for you to dodge if they do turn
you I'm burning everything sports Earth
policy was Jill I'll burn it all
in fact I'm amazed we even just burn
this whole place down yet
consider it a different ending this
area's upsetting oh I can light it I
have a I have this handy-dandy lighter
oh I just don't think you're facing it
completely okay thanks this is like one
of those things that I would straight-up
just be like oh I guess I don't need it
there and then it would three hours
later I'd realized that I just did it
wrong I thought I was maybe I need to be
way close there you go weird that is
weird
the rooms not creepier at all much
better oh yeah okay sweet
I like your caution thank you
I learned it from you upsetting me all
the time I wish I had go to your
defensive items I'm just curious
actually have one Eggers oh yeah I
accidentally used to on that nice see
okay you don't even have to kill this
guy you've got a table that you can can
mouse him around but it's my
recommendation
well once I go in here then I'm stuck
hurry well then what do I do in there
like I said if he gets too close while
you're trying to figure it out just wait
it out like any bullet you could save
it's gonna be useful I know he's stuck
what an idiot I Moran
go this way you dum-dum
nice is there anything else in here
don't feel comfortable Oh what is this
wine these glasses
hmm it's nice so should I do the B
puzzle now yeah you can fight if I do
that you're on this side of mansion
kitchen oh wait there's also this
downstairs
this place looks nice shield is new
helmet honestly I don't want to freakin
go in there well it's locked so it is
where Richard stumbled out of that place
can go to hell oh haha where's that
light coming from
there's nothing lit in that brazier that
guy's freaking face so upsetting he's
just gonna hang out there it's he okay
can I talk to him like a six-pack or
something
I'm okay the others he doesn't look okay
no he looks pretty [ __ ] up like I have
these plants eat one alright so you know
there's a locked door with this ducky
you don't have so you know you'll come
back through this way yes I would leave
those oh I okay I understand what you
mean
alright I think I should do the B puzzle
again mm-hmm what do you think does that
seem okay yeah you're pretty close to it
right now and then I'd like to save
because I feel like well you're gonna
need to go oh sorry you only have one
spot you need to for the B puzzle I just
don't want to lose all this progress
wasn't there save room real close yeah
but I guess yeah I would go to save room
deposit some stuff and then do the B and
then save it great that's why I meant so
is not to using gribbins although you
need to save a lot on this difficulty to
actually use up all the agreements
where's the save room it's right to my
left right you're on the top floor yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that carpet just
moved did not I can't believe I died
makes you lose like 30 minutes of
progress it's like kind of gut-wrenching
to die like that like that's the real
fear honestly
well you redeemed yourself thank you
because I don't need it now I'm gonna
come back correct I'm gonna do the B
puzzle I'm gonna come back yeah
well plus you freed up more space for
that first aid kit green herbs that's
correct if you so choose to take them I
think I really like just went for it
with that wall decorating that wall yeah
that one wall there like this is the one
all right all right just making sure
that I know what the hell I'm doing cuz
I keep like forgetting I have the bad
memory in all honesty to most of these
things get in there girlfriend wait yeah
yeah crack horn isn't she gonna mention
Richard oh by the way Richard's half - a
snake bitten I sprinted across the
mansion - zombies reanimate themselves
but you don't seem to carriers gonna
leave okay never mind
I'll see you later have a nice shoulder
pads to go stars
what are those shoulder pads attached to
like that action huh never mind she's
got like body armor
look I just like to imagine she walked
into H&M and saw that thing on the rack
oh my god it's just my size and it's on
sale 20% off that makes a 200 bucks it
says steal or she could just steal it
Jill's super klepto stealing bees off
the walls
stealing bees
no better yet I'd like to imagine the
thing was a hand-me-down from like an
older sibling I've got some body I'm I
don't wear anymore
I really need it sophomore year
chemistry class I'll take it hang out it
Spencer's mansion his parents are away
we're having a party you keep talking
while you're gonna solve this puzzle
yeah you're doing a great job I messed
up again
got it nice
the B only comes alive every other time
by the way no it doesn't it's always
been come alive now see you're good take
it hate that this shoot is a freaking
huge where your shoulder pads now Jill
nice Oh simple enough that time got some
slots left you want to bring some
medical items back I think I will oh
wait did I get everything from that room
yeah well use your map to check
yeah it's 100% complete noise all right
this room however is not all right so I
could take a green and red and combine
them and then get the first-aid kit as
well if you want there are those green
herbs behind the bed but you can just
remember those later if you need him I
don't think you'll need them but it's
nice to have them what I don't know it's
just nice to have them that way you know
they're they're deep down in your heart
looks like you ever done like an actual
cheese tasting no they like what I taste
cheese all the time what kind of
question is that a formal one that not
formal but if you go to like a
charcuterie what makes it no formal
listen I formally eat cheese all the
time just dress up and really nicely and
atvs home they cut into it and then they
like smear it on a piece of paper to
give to you and yeah
eat it off of it well like breeze and
nicer cheese's that's ridiculous
just yeah okay you haven't lived till
you've been do a charcuterie tasting I
disagree just go home and eat some
cheese but you just what do you do
unwrap Kraft singles and just slam them
in your face all there's different types
of cheese and Kraft singles and for
someone who's been to a charcuterie
Nandhini you should know more about
cheese there's like just go for the door
cheddar mozzarella insults are earning
you Swiss one misleading Gouda I'm gonna
use it at my all right I'd literally I'd
like to save okay I just feel like
enough has happened that I'd like to not
redo okay is that okay yeah it's up to
you all right I'm making the call okay
are you upset with me no I'm gonna take
you to a charcuterie this weekend but no
I don't want to go to a charcuterie
you're just being stubborn it's gonna go
it's gonna be fantastic I don't I'll go
by myself all right I'm gonna you know
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna eat some
cheese at home and it's me great I'm
gonna pay way less than you for the same
cheese
I don't need the windcrest right now
just as a oh I can get rid of it look
you're gonna save yeah just a three all
right
you also have you could refill one of
your kerosene right now oh yeah I will
do that
burn some zoms I like that noise turn it
up turn it sound like feel like a
secretary I just think I feel like a
secretary there's only you know what you
tell me like oh there's this noise make
you feel safe and the truth is the only
thing that makes me feel safe is the
saving noise because I feel like hah if
I die I I have so much more so much less
to reap like yeah like I just I'm fine
I hate dying and losing progress I think
it just like breaks my heart it's just a
real line be like alright what did I do
that I need to redo I need to figure out
where I am again in this world yeah so I
don't need this right now no cuz I got a
lot more doors I can open with this one
yeah open your mouth quick I'm just r2
is a quick button for your map on ps4 by
the way okay I got okay you could know a
prairie yeah you have the dog detective
and there was like a secret remember you
saw like a little portal for a key that
you need yes I would tell you you do not
have that key so don't go get attacked
by dogs again okay also she's like a
good system he's long hallways
so you've been into all these rooms
clearly except for this like tight
u-shaped one yeah but to get there you'd
have to use that door for the final time
I thought I had three turns with it
yeah and you accidentally accidentally
used - oh yeah you have one more I'm
trying to think if you could use it
right now you could isn't there another
way to get there yeah you can go through
this bottom right corridor now but you
have to contend with a dog okay I'll
just dodge him I'm really good at it or
you could continue - I'll dodge a dog
but you have to go I would just
recommend saving that door for now
because that door is on its tests so
I'll dodge dog okay so you go up a long
way yeah okay so I'm gonna go in here
know that no you have to go all the way
down the main hall first to the right oh
if you don't want to use that door okay
so but there are a couple doors over
here you haven't tried it on the left
mm-hmm of them of one floor one mhm okay
actually no what yeah so
yeah you can eat okay so you can go back
to the main hall and then go to that one
we're just talking about or you can go
to the west wing to try out doors either
one I think is gonna take you can do
them to either an order it'll take the
same out of time but also probably like
what 10 minutes left in this episode
okay well yeah let's do that actually to
the East Wing so not this actually okay
actually you know what go back to the
Sabre really quick get the the mask and
put it in your inventory so we can dump
them off you can like just to get them
out of like you're gonna be over that
way anyway got it we could start
depositing masks I understand on those
but nothing happens when you deposit a
mask does it maybe that I feel like you
just gave something away
oh I'm just telling you right now bring
it you'll need the musical scores semi
centers but not now well once I dumped
the mask I actually bring like a green
herb just in case for the dog if it was
something huge and serious I would tell
you me more than a greeter should I am
judging by your past performance oh my
god that was one death I think all right
don't don't use that door all right
don't make it easier later just go yeah
go main hall
so we'll do this and then you can
probably save and then I'll call it an
episode this will take like 10 minutes
ish don't tell the people the ending
well ideally this will take like ten
minutes but who knows
oh my god that's rude I'm not insulting
yours but feel like you are commenting
on the game's capricious nature
copernicus all right
so where are we going go down
no actually wait while you're up here
there's a red door lower it up check it
out I will drag it out it's a door on
the right
oh yeah you're getting closer to
discarding that key as well oh really
yeah once you use all the doors they'll
say you don't need to see I know but I
didn't realize I was that close well I
mean every doors closer Oh Lord
actually let me see Airman Tory not open
your inventory quick I'm not messing
with you that's where oh [ __ ] I need to
I to us lots don't I
no no no you're good you're good you're
good just continue down this now that I
think you can do stuff here
Oh magazine table table meeting though
that'd be great if she tried jamming
that table into her gown it's not
working
I don't understand I just get closer to
him
I can't marry you're killing me there
you go
shut up dog
I'm like pretty afraid of dogs since
episode 2 you should be they're kind of
tougher to knock back that you fast Oh
foliage in place of a stand Oh God check
out that sweet baby next to him who is
that who is that click on it again
Forest has given up the ghost that's
such a badass way to say someone died
bottom left this green or dead can I
take his gun
try it out
nice David grenade launcher or as I call
it the Great Gatsby watts mm-hmm
remember the acid rounds Barry left for
you in a safe room the acid rounds yeah
you picked I don't know if you're member
at the under last up so when you enter
that safe round there was like ammo and
first-day sprays you can load those I
can load occurs into that thing quite
some time okay some plants
no no that's facing him no wait
mash buttons son what a yeah I would run
yeah don't worry I would just run just
run why takes more than the average
zombie why oh that's a creepy shot oh
god that's a creepy shot he's fast I got
hurt I need to eat yeah
oh you got on red he really mess you up
dang alright like reddish yellow I use
it yeah yes so that's not okay that's
not very good
should I get another plan in my butt cuz
I'm gonna be messing with dogs right
just go get one of the ones from me
Richard you're pretty close to it but
yeah if you're gonna it's a good call if
you're gonna be you don't wanna screw
things up with the dog I almost wouldn't
mind if you died though we need an
episode to end like on an Empire Strikes
Back lower you know carbon freezing
chamber and
this is not cut off my arm a dramatic
triple-a film it's my life
okay stop it stop it okay so alright so
I'm going downstairs and to the right
where the dogs are mm-hmm
it's a shortcut you made when you came
back through the other side of the door
but there's dogs should I just kill them
no this one's easy to dodge remember oh
no no no you did you killed one of a
member the one that bit you in the butt
would have been the one other one they
came crashing through the window I
killed that [ __ ] so youse have one to
dodge so it's through here mm-hmm
that other door you try the other time
it's a helmet door okay and then I'm
gonna go through this red hallway mm-hmm
which is support the dog is mm-hmm and
then I'm gonna do that labyrinth of
corridors oh my god and then I'm gonna
go where follow it along is there any
more that you shaped one no you already
explored all those rooms that's where
you got the shotgun and the bathtub
empty a u-shaped door no no the red door
to the u-shaped room here no bottom
under south part yeah they're gonna all
right now we're on the same page mm-hmm
yeah here we go mansions you think I'd
know how to navigate them better
considering how much time I spend in
them because I am so rich
Mary Kistner like Mary cash that's right
from selling all my memory to dodge some
[ __ ] yo okay canines more like Kano he
doesn't even see ya I'm an idiot
alright I had no idea was that easy
simple I thought dogs would be more
difficult why just follow this along
absolutely hate that camera mm-hmm
someone kind of squeeze through a door
no Scout just coughs coughs coughs Koko
get ready to dodge though just go
through my going go follow yeah nice
left yeah nice okay I was actually
really worried about oh my god it's good
though now that corridor this is the
last time you really need to use that
corridor for the most part the Hollett
way ever again
well you won't necessarily need to I'm
not gonna steer you wrong
oh my god if you had died I woulda just
made the excuse that you were insulting
me earlier that was a creepy noise
wasn't it
nope no where am I going down there so
that's not the door you want to go
through you want to go to one of the ops
aside the hallway
what so am I going to the left yes
there's one cheese arms there on the
left no no no no left they go
so one fuzzy so then behind you was that
walkway to where that door with the dogs
and there's that like a little key that
you didn't have okay so PSA
there's a freaking sound in here the
puzzle here it yeah
Jurassic Park themes but stuck in my
head you know
Raptors about to pounce on you a crow
out there Jesus I really want to shoot
that crow it's gonna be the same thing
just notice one two there's there yeah
so wait it's there's a whole other side
is quarterman I know I'm just looking so
there's a guy with a sword and yellow
mm-hmm
there's a guy with a pen in red hmm
there's a I don't know what that is
a staff a crown staff god I don't like
it Oh God
same guy mm-hmm the other side same guy
same guy bracelet necklace crown there's
a switch at the bottom of the picture
press it no okay so I feel like I have
some knowledge stop it I hate those
crows I'm gonna read this again bring
the lights of the truth to the three
spirits all right well that didn't help
yeah though on the other side's more
useful is this is this about order
though because how would I know what
order it is not really let's kind of ish
just like what's discerning about her
she's wearing three things she's wearing
a necklace a bracelet a bracelet a
necklace and a crown please don't press
that switch I'm sorry I don't want you
what what happens in it don't worry
about it so do I get key owed can I so
he's wearing a bracelet mm-hmm so I'm
not ready yet I understand that you
understand what's going on but I don't
mm-hmm like they're each wearing a piece
mm-hmm you know you yeah you can
bracelet you can experiment with these
ones but do not experiment with her
until you're sure bracelet necks of
weird phrasing bracelet necklace crown
and she's wearing a bracelet and
necklace and a crown mm-hmm Oh
so there's colors her crown is green her
necklace is purple and her bracelet is
red yeah um that doesn't really help
though because this guy's bracelet is
yellow yeah exactly so you can
experiment with these three just don't
press her switch tell you sure
okay I understand I mean I haven't I
don't understand but I feel like I have
a better understanding can I change it
to more colors or just those no don't be
rude
are you actually asking me well on this
side you're giving it away you just said
don't be rude mm-hmm that's my trick and
then you insult me for it that's great
ah I forget what color I want it was
from the top to bottom green purple red
oh so he's good
presumably he's got a green crown purple
necklace red bracelet got it
Oh necklace is purple mm-hmm so now I
just need to make that this should be it
I'm a [ __ ] genius oh crap
I'll turn it from the other side that'll
probably make it red what if you press
the switch and then the image change
from a guy holding a sword is the big
middle finger got me yeah orange purple
red do you say purple yeah ergo Steve
Urkel um it's from celebrity jeopardy
they're like this color starts with
purple and the guy goes what is lat
purple it's a good joke
I like Sean Connery the best on those I
know he's always talking about your
Becks mom it's an innocent death if you
get this wrong what happens you're gonna
get right but what happens was that
crows thank you
they don't kill you no just let me do it
sweet
no oh I think I know where I am
can I shut this you know I just hate
those crows I know where I am and I
already have a amass key so I can return
- mmhmm yes - masks - mouse keys or -
your mom came to drop bombs stop it oh
sorry I know they're mm-hmm that's the
stuff mm-hmm then you got the shotgun
shelter there I love that shot there
it's all making sense now we're
approaching a realm where things make
sense we could save this ish and then I
don't think we are gonna save that I
think we're just gonna keep going keep
on no I want to say I always get anxiety
is there any punishment for putting the
wrong mask in the wrong spot I would
just negate any chance of that happening
just put him on the right one
so you have eyes nose ears and then
what's the other one mouth eyes nose
mouth
that's all three I think yeah yeah right
no up above as the eyes nose mouth ones
whoa what is that oh I don't like it
I have no mouth but I must scream oh I
read that just the other day it's really
upsetting
that's one debate just double check an
AI right that has humans that is slowly
torturing for yeah you just like hates
humans he's keeping him for no reason
well I think he has a reason but it's
still pretty unnecessary ooh
blood on the camera it's a Michael Bay
ish I understand what happened can I get
in there
two more chains all right well I guess
that's a lot of progress
mm-hmm-hmm save room to cap it or and
they're right here we could any right
here misfire
is that your cue for ending episode just
spinning her frantically yeah that's
where I know that I'm successful all
right well we're gonna throw record
another episode ready for this if you're
not gonna go to save room okay all right
we'll do that
thank you guys for watching this was
episode 4 of resident knievel playing
the original resident evil will
remastered but you know
we'll see you guys in episode 5 thanks
for watching
don't kill me you know almost about know
you